Chúng tôi không có ngày 1 năm tháng 8, cho biết sẽ cơ đặt phái viên của chính phố vì vẫn đề Trung đông ông Chương 2 quan tới khu vực này,
nhằm tìm kiếm các biển pháp giảm lâu tháng thẳng, cho bất cảnh xúc độ cạnh Trung đông tiếp tục dịch biến tức tạp.
Các biểu tại của họ báo thương kì, trứ phân ngôn bộ ngoại sâu Trung Quốc màu nền khẩn định,
bắt kênh sẽ tiếp tục dưới chiến lê là bối tất cả các biên quan, thúc đại đối thoại và tăng cửa nước lực hoa dài.
Chúng của chương săng việc kéo dài và léo thông suốt đồ thông có lợi cho bất kì biên nèo, và chỉ đối thoại đảng phán mới có thể giúp giúp giải quý cơ bất đồng.
Thưa bà mào nền, trong những ngày gần đây, ngoại trường Trung Quốc vương nghỉ đã có các cuộc đẹp đàn với nhiều đối tác cu tế,
bà gồm nghe, í vang, ông MAM Pháp, Israel, ở lập xeu và cơ tử vụ của gọi là thử nhất uài Ê, nhằm chào đổi bị tình hình khu vực,
cung nghe, bộ ngoại sâu nghe, các bài tỏ quan ngày bây giờ biến ngày càng số đi tại Trung đông,
mắt cơ bà kêu gọi các bây liên quan chấm rất càng đồng thu định, đồng thời nhớ mạnh rằng các cuộc tấn công nhà bà dân thường và cơ sở hạ tăng dân sự là không thể chếm nhận được.
Ngà chứ rằng việc kiêm trế với thu bài các giải pháp chính trị ngoại sâu, là cần thiết đề ngâm chẳng quý cơ xin lột lần rộng trong khu vực.